and I'm loving this look on you thank
you so much you are very tall I am white
but then I'm not so you are very
beautiful you're just an average height
I'm 5 11. okay you're not out no no but
Utah
on that my friend Mike a friend yes Mom
just a friend what is going on here who
is this guy he's my boyfriend your
boyfriend
I think it's great kid I love seeing you
with those three gentlemen over there
you guys just light up the screen in
this film you have so much heart and you
provide so much joy as well and an odd
comforting kind of way you know
um how fun was it to be able to play
wife to bill again in this film what is
it about the chemistry you two have it
just worked well we were on stage when
you're on stage with somebody for like
months and months and months the way
Billy Irwin and I were you you either
end up adoring that person until the end
of time or you hate each other's guts so
I would say the corner you adore him
adore him I would do anything to be
working with him again he's so much fun
well I adored seeing a human Jim Parsons
character together because whenever you
shared screens and scenes together it
they were just fantastic what was it
about Gem and Ben though that really
brought this love story to life why were
they the perfect pairing to tell this
story
boy you know I can't really answer that
question uh I I do think that Ben
is a like breakout movie star happening
here um they'll then Aldrich and we
haven't seen him in this Coast very much
and he's a Brit and he's just fabulous
and then we all know Jim uh it's it's
hard to say they just they're kind of
these two roles I feel like each of you
were you know from Bill Ben Jim and
yourself you were just it was a perfect
casting and other perfect casting
happening was for 84 Brady when the
trailer dropped the internet with wild
Sally so what will you fondly remember
of your time with those other legendary
ladies well that's almost for another
day
we're gonna do a lot of talking about
that very soon because it comes out very
soon but you know the truth is I was
there because Jane has been one of my
good friends yeah boy it's hard we were
trying to think for how long it really
has been until in the early 80s she
literally knocked on my door and said
you know come on we're going to lunch
and she's been so important to me and as
a female friend and mentor and all sorts
of things it's so important to have
women like that yeah I've been with so
many of us were heartbroken to hear the
news that sadly Jane is is battling
cancer again how did you and the ladies
rally you're just doing great yeah she's
doing great I recently caught up with
her for an interview for a film but it
was before she announced no she's doing
you know like shockingly well really
like weirdly well today I know I think
she lied about the whole thing because
nobody does that but she's she's doing
really really well finally we love 30 we
love celebrations and anniversaries at
E.T next year marks the 30th anniversary
of Mrs Doubtfire what is the memory that
you will remember always of your time
with Robin Williams from that oh boy
that's like a whole hour and a half we
almost don't have time for that it's
just so much yeah so much good things to
remember about that yeah so much
[Music]
foreign